anyway i get there and i thought in my
head well the whole time i'm riding
there i'm just furious and the guy
oh the uber driver
kept telling me he had asthma and about
his
journey with asthma
dude we got bigger
fish to fry in the world right now than
somebody having an asthma journey bro
maybe if you can't breathe well maybe
god don't
want you round yeah
have you thought about that huh puff
puff
maybe if you can't take a hit off the
world
correctly maybe the lord's looking for
you
so anyway an hour and a half i listen to
you know captain [ __ ] camp puff
talk about his 65 years dude with 65
65 years of lung issues and he had
crosses hanging
everywhere in the uber he had
i mean there was a cross there was a
cross here
you know at one point i reached behind
my ear and i pulled out a cross like he
had there was
i don't know if this guy lives if he had
a vampire as an ex-wife i don't know
what's going on
but the lord i mean i guess the lord was
with us
for sure it was an uber pool because
they had there's no way there weren't a
couple of straight-up disciples in the
trunk
and so you know anyway we go oh the guy
kept having to pull over to breathe
fresh air
the guy kept having to pull over to
breathe
fresh air in new jersey
off the turnpike there ain't no fresh
air
there ain't no fresh air about a
turnpike dude
bring a bag of air from somewhere else
fill up a balloon from damn kansas or
something
and get that thing you know get that
thing trucked in or trained in
oh
so we pull over this is the second time
we pulled over to get fresh air in
i'm not sure where it was some little
town
uh and a guy
comes up to the car we stop it's
literally like we have to stop for a
minute and he will
the first time he put his head out the
window and the second time he got out of
the
vehicle to breathe this is
this and i'm just i'm like ah
it's already this is a 200 uber
and it was a small car
okay it was small
and some of you guys are thinking well
theo you know you've made some money why
don't you get a nice get somebody
i agree but that's just not who i am i
don't that's not
i i don't like to get i try to be
thrifty
you know that's just who i am i don't
you know that's just who i am it's just
in my nature
you know sometimes i don't want to uh
sometimes i don't want to give myself
you know the creature comforts i don't
want to take care of myself like that
and i probably should
because then i just get more stressed
so anyway dude we're out there and a
brother i'll be honest straight up
brother
urban brother whatever however you want
to term it you know
um comes up and starts asking if we want
to buy
some drugs um
and the asthma guy the uh
the driver starts asking me
like it kind of directs him towards me
like i don't [ __ ]
like what is going on here i don't i the
guy
i i'm i am i'm i'm paying to be on this
shh
this shitty
adventure with freaking billy bad
lungs up here who can't handle the world
and now i gotta tell that i don't want
any drugs that dudes
starts looking at two of the crosses if
they're for sale like dog we ain't doing
this [ __ ] right now
like i'm just you know what y'all doing
around here
we're here because he this guy
this guy wants some [ __ ] this guy
wants some fresh air
by this railroad tracks and by these
walgreens
that's why we're here that's why we're
here
and just nobody wants to believe you bro
when you're out there like that
so i'm just fear and i'm just like i
can't wait to drink now i'm gonna drink
gasoline i'm thinking about i'm thinking
i'm gonna drink ethanol i'm gonna drink
i am going to have someone else do a two
two three four five eight balls
a 40 ball i'm gonna have somebody do at
least a 32 ball of cocaine then i'm
gonna
drink their blood that's where i'm at
that's where i'm at i'm not doing super
well good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one